what is the meaning of life Andre
we we talked about sort of
the universe having a conversation with
us humans or with the systems we create
to try to answer for the universe for
the creator of the universe to notice us
we're trying to create systems that are
loud enough
just answer back
I don't know that's the meaning of life
that's like meaning of life for some
people the first level answer I would
say is anyone can choose their own
meaning of life because we are conscious
entity and it's beautiful number one but
uh I do think that like a deeper meaning
of life if someone is interested is uh
along the lines of like what the hell is
the oldest and like why and if you look
at the into fundamental physics and the
quantum field Theory and the standard
model they're like way like very
complicated and um
there's this like you know 19 free
parameter parameters of our universe and
like what's going on with all this stuff
and why is it here and can I hack it can
I work with it is there a message for me
am I supposed to create a message
and so I think there's some fundamental
answers there but I think there's
actually even like you can't actually
really make dent in those without more
time and so to me also there's a big
question around just getting more time
honestly
yeah that's kind of like what I think
about quite a bit as well so kind of the
ultimate
or at least first way to sneak up to the
why question is to try to escape
uh the system the universe yeah and then
for that you sort of uh backtrack and
say okay for that that's going to be
take a very long time so the why
question boils down from an engineering
perspective to how do we extend yeah I
think that's the question number one
practically speaking because you can't
um you're not gonna calculate the answer
to the deeper questions in the time you
have and that could be extending your
own lifetime or extending just the
lifetime of human civilization of
whoever wants to not many people might
not want that yeah but I think people
who do want that I think
I think it's probably possible uh and I
don't I don't know that people
fully realize this I kind of feel like
people think of death as an
inevitability but at the end of the day
this is a physical system some things go
wrong uh it makes sense why things like
this happen evolutionarily speaking and
uh there's most certainly interventions
that uh that mitigate it that would be
interesting if death is eventually
looked at as
as a fascinating thing that used to
happen to humans I don't think it's
unlikely I think it's I think it's
likely
and it's up to our imagination to try to
predict what the world without death
looks like yeah it's hard to I think the
values will completely change
could be I don't I don't really buy all
these ideas that oh without death
there's no meaning there's nothing as
I don't intuitively buy all those
arguments I think there's plenty of
meaning plenty of things to learn
they're interesting exciting I want to
know I want to calculate uh I want to
improve the condition of
all the humans and organisms that are
alive and the way we find meaning might
change we there is a lot of humans
probably including myself that finds
meaning in the finiteness of things but
that doesn't mean that's the only source
of meaning yeah I do think many people
will will go with that which I think is
great I love the idea that people can
just choose their own adventure like you
you are born as a conscious free entity
by default I'd like to think and um you
have your unalienable rights for Life uh
in the pursuit of happiness I don't know
if you have that in the nature the
landscape of happiness and you can
choose your own adventure mostly and
that's not it's not fully true but I
still am pretty sure I'm an NPC but
um an NPC can't know it's an NPC
there could be different degrees and
levels of consciousness I don't think
there's a more beautiful way to end it
uh Andre you're an incredible person I'm
really honored you would talk with me
everything you've done for the machine
learning world for the AI world
to just inspire people to educate
millions of people it's been it's been
great and I can't wait to see what you
do next it's been an honor man thank you
so much for talking today awesome thank
you